you don't know why places offer you a  bottle of water when you walk in the  door it's not because they want you to  be better hydrated it's because they're  trying to use reciprocity to get you to  buy stuff so a research study came out  where what they did was they had people  hand strangers a can of coca-cola before  asking them to buy tickets to a raffle  for charity the people who got a can of  coke bought twice as many raffle tickets  as the people who did it and they ran  the study again and asked them whether  they liked the person or not and it  turned out even if they didn't like the  person at all the number of raffle  tickets that was purchased remained  unchanged which means that the power of  reciprocity the power of giving first is  so strong that it'll compel people to  buy things even from people they don't  like and that's what you should use in  your own business for more videos like  this in the future go ahead and click  follow and i'll see in the next